we can crisis talks and an emergency
deal
saving one of the world's most important
but troubled Banks a merger brokered by
the Swiss government seeing credits
Swiss consumed by rival UBS
a bank worth eight billion on Friday
sold for a little over three billion the
Takeover of credits is by UBS is the
best solution for restoring the
confidence that has been lacking in
financial markets recently and for best
managing the risk to our country and its
citizens
rescuing One bank to avert panic and
further failures
Panic caused by the downfall of Silicon
Valley Bank
further shotways came from credit
suisse's need for a 54 billion dollar
loan from the Swiss central bank then a
run on First Republic Bank caused some
of America's largest banks to loan 30
billion dollars all while the share
price and confidence plummeted in Credit
Suisse necessitating a takeover of
Switzerland's second largest lender by
UBS
Swiss emergency Powers will push through
this rapid takeover without shareholder
approval
and to prevent a run on the bank
Switzerland is providing a safety net of
a hundred billion dollars
having been Chief Financial Officer
during the last Global financial crisis
and well aware of the importance of a
solid balance sheet especially in
challenging Times Like These a new UBS
will remain Rock Solid
the ghosts of the 2008 financial crisis
loomed over the fate of the 167 year old
Swiss giant brought to the brink by bad
bets scandals and wider banking anxiety
financial markets remain fragile across
the globe amid Rising interest rates
the hope is Switzerland has prevented
further turmoil whether they've
succeeded will become clearer once
markets open
Rob Harris Sky News